c'est vrai que j'aime pas tellement les
prêts je n'aime pas les balades en forêt
je n'aime pas les champignons accueillir
les animaux
je crois que je m'en fous
bonsoir
comment ça va bien vous traversez en ce
moment une période particulièrement
heureuse de votre vie Marina d'abord au
plan personnel au plan personnel votre
vie affective et particulièrement
épanouie cet enfant
non c'est vrai l'être qui partage votre
vie est un être humain particulièrement
remarquable non je pense
que non mais ça se passe bien voilà
question argent ça va bien aussi
un pognon fou PEL c e l PEA
et c'est tout
pour moi vous venez d'acheter un
appartement oui il est bien il est très
bien
c'est 12 rue de Wagram et le code c'est
21 89
alors ça donc voilà question amour
argent
sur le plan professionnel ça va encore
mieux vous venez de tourner le premier
film des Robins des bois sous la
direction d'Alain Chabat ça s'appelle
très bien parce qu'on aura à le dire je
pense j'ai quelques amis qui l'ont vu
comment ça se dit comme
de mettre fait toute seule et je leur ai
dit très tôt
votre vocation est née au contact on
sait ce qu'on lit partout je fais même
pas si c'est vrai au contact d'un
baby-sitter c'est vrai ça oui oui
bien sûr
il a une compagnie à Toulouse
c'était dans tous les journaux
a proposé à Marina le rôle Daniel dans
L'École des femmes et puis ensuite ça a
continué Britannicus tous les classiques
et alors ensuite vous raconter ceux avec
qui vous deviendrez les Robins des Bois
nulle part ailleurs et puis au cinéma
alors je vais faire quand même vous avez
dans la tour Montparnasse infernale
voilà dans Astérix mission Cléopâtre
dans le raid Djamel Bensalah dans Mais
qui a tué Pamela Rose qui était un très
bon succès cet été et puis dans un film
de Duty déjà premier film que vous avez
fait avec lui qui s'appelait fille perdu
cheveux gras c'était bien c'est vous qui
chantez oui oh maintenant il existe une
machine et c'est vrai vous rentrez la
voix de quelqu'un qui chante fou et ça
sort juste
avant ben oui ça existe
alors vos rêves les plus fous se sont
réalisés marinages je crois qu'on peut
le dire non
oui
une partie
c'est bizarre je sens qu'il y a un
derrière
un moment de bonheur un vrai moment de
bonheur Méline le Panthéon non la pluie
de pétale de rose Didier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ça
bienvenue au gîte ça s'appelle de Claude
Duty avec Marina Foïs Philippe arène
Annie Grégorio Julie Depardieu Michael
Malaunay Sébastien Barrio
il est bien monté Sébastien oui oui
je m'en fous
bien je vais faire le pitch
alors
proie au stress de la vie urbaine qui a
décidé de tout plaquer et d'aller en
Provence pour reprendre un gîte rural
voilà l'histoire on a tous envie un
moment vous aussi avec Christine
j'imagine on a tous eu envie à un moment
de d'aller en Provence dans la loge qui
m'a dit moi je veux tout laisser tomber
monter un titre rurale
vraiment des fromages alors quand vous
arrivez dans ce gîte rural tout irait
bien quelques détails près d'abord vous
vous avez jamais vu le truc que vous
avez repris votre fille paraît lui il
l'a vu mais il y a très très longtemps
la vendeuse la fille qui vend elle est
partie avec un cracheur de feu sans sans
laisser d'adresse sans vous briefer il y
a un audit dans le même bled qui est
quand même vachement mieux que le vôtre
voilà et alors vous rencontrez en
arrivant là une fille qui veut pas
partir qui est là
angélique quoi qui est la bonne femme
qui s'occupe du truc qui s'appelle Annie
Grégorio et qui la Venise quel employait
encombrante et qui veut rester voilà
donc tout ça n'est pas si simple vous
l'avez bien compris plus la clientèle
qui ne plaît pas beaucoup à Caroline mon
personnage qui est pas très elle est ni
pour les scouts ni pour les actrices
porno que joue Julie Depardieu à
merveille ni pour les Belges elle rêve
d'une clientèle un peu plus un peu plus
chic selon ses critères à elle et
effectivement
ça va être une sorte de d'énormes rasage
pour elle ça fait longtemps que j'avais
pas autant ri à un film
je l'ai vu avant que ça sort deux jours
avant et j'étais appelé tout de suite
vraiment c'est des gens des comédiens
bien dans un film bien dans une comédie
Henri tout le temps et en plus on se dit
en fait ça dit quelque chose parce qu'il
y a dans les comédies et c'est un film
vraiment qui fonctionne
fermés
alors moralité de l'histoire le couple
ne se retrouve pas donc changer de vie à
40 ans vous dites il vaut mieux que ça
reste un fantasme finalement
c'est risqué et que peut-être le truc de
changer de vie peut-être que c'est juste
un fantasme et qu'il faut pas le
réaliser mais peut-être qu'on se dit ça
quand on a une vie qui nous convient
c'est pas vraiment un rôle de
composition parce que vous dites j'ai
une ruralité limitée vous n'êtes pas
très campagne en fait non c'est un truc
qui vous c'est vrai que j'aime pas
tellement les prés je n'aime pas les
balades en forêt je n'aime pas les
champignons accueillir les animaux
je crois que je m'en fous non c'est pas
c'est pas des trucs qui m'attirent quoi
moi j'aime bien j'aime bien la ville
j'aime bien voir plein de gens j'aime
bien qu'il y ait des cinémas avec des
films en VO j'aime bien pouvoir acheter
des cigarettes très tard
c'est le bricolage
j'aime beaucoup et je sais il y a Sylvie
Testud qui va arriver aussi j'aime tout
ce qui est enduit coffrage de tuyaux
c'est une passion je trouve ça très
intéressant je fais avec de l'aggloméré
chaque année mon père m'offre un outil
ponceuse perceuse rabot etc
voilà c'est mes activités parasolaires
et alors c'est bon ce personnage que
vous interprétez ramène tout à elle sur
que même quand elle s'occupe de Julie
Depardieu qui est une star du porno qui
veut qui veut décrocher et elle le fait
parce que ça lui plaît de se voir en
train d'aider quelqu'un
voilà c'est formidable de l'aider donc
elle l'aide elle ramène tout elle
pourrait être actrice en fait
l'animatrice de télé c'est un truc comme
ça alors c'est vrai on a tous tendance
et vous aussi nous tous à se considérer
un petit peu comme le comme le centre du
monde
que le but c'est pas ça le but c'est de
faire un peu vite de lever la tête c'est
ce que j'essaye de faire non je dis ça
parce que vous avez dit une phrase dans
une interview dans un journal que j'aime
beaucoup et que je vais essayer de
m'appliquer à moi-même cette année ça
fait partie des grandes résolutions de
la rentrée il faut essayer de ne pas se
subir
réfléchissez à ça
va être dur pour toi le problème tu n'as
pas de vendre pour permettre de purger
votre ego on va aller plus loin dans le
nombrilisme de façon à ce que vous
fassiez comme on dit dans le midi une
four de nombrilisme une four une four
ouais il faut quand on se fait une
fourbe
chocolat ça veut dire qu'on bouffe du
chocolat puis après on en mange plus
pendant 15 jours on va se faire une four
de nombrilisme une overdose si vous
préférez
et on va faire Marina une interview je
me la pète
[Musique]
le dernier avoir été soumis à
l'interview je me la pète était votre
ami Jean-Paul Rouve qui était
extrêmement brillant dans cette
interview et je ne doute pas que vous le
soyez aussi
bien dites-moi ça vous gêne pas de
d'être obligé de venir ici pour faire la
promo de votre fille
non parce que tout ce qui peut me
permettre de parler de moi longuement
ennuyeusement nos flèche
et si je me laisse pousser les cheveux
et qu'est-ce que je bois le matin
du café
[Rires]
bien est-ce que vous pensez que le
cinéma français vous mérite Marina
oui il a besoin de moi
en plus c'est vrai est-ce que j'imagine
que votre talent votre succès doivent
susciter un certain nombre de jalousie
mon talent et mon succès sont tout
d'abord mérités et ceux qui sont jaloux
perdent leur temps puisqu'ils
n'arriveront jamais sous l'ongle de ma
cheville ça fait du bien
c'est vrai qu'Isabelle Huppert vous
demande souvent des conseils
oui mais alors franchement j'ai pas le
temps pour pour autre chose à faire je
me donne des conseils à moi-même ça
marche je me pose des questions et je me
résous
ça doit être un supportable médiocrité
des autres acteurs français non pour
vous la médiocrité des Robins des bois
je n'en peux plus de ce boulet
à votre niveau à votre niveau de jeu
dans le monde y a qui il y a Kidman et
de Niro avec une perruque quoi c'est
tout non Kidman
d'accord ok j'ai fait une connerie là ça
vous avez
la comparaison est pas hyper flatteuse
pour moi ok ok
[Rires]
vous avez quoi que les autres n'ont pas
le reste
si on vous avait dit qu'un jour c'est
vous qui jetterez Brad Pitt est-ce que
vous auriez cru à l'époque à ça
oui mais alors Brad Pitt j'ai couché
avec lui pour lui rendre service parce
que c'est pas du tout mon genre et c'est
vrai je pardon j'aime pas les blonds moi
j'ai une couleur
cheveux je les trouve très bien
[Rires]
Marina est-ce que c'est vrai que vous
coupez sans arrêt votre portable parce
que les réalisateurs vous appellent
c'est vrai Soderberg Philbert
qu'est-ce qui vous reste comme objectif
dans la vie maintenant mais rien je
crois qu'il est temps que je me retire
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu